today's episode is brought to you by one
of my favorite places to be on earth and
that's gray black pizza you know I liked
being when I was young I liked being in
Louisiana and as an adult I liked being
in great block and you can go to great
block pizza 18:11 Pico Boulevard in Los
Angeles great block get that hitter welp
it's still me and I got something to say
to you guys and that something is
Skillshare all of us have skills and all
of us don't have a lot of different
skills well that can change in a
heartbeat and that heartbeat is
Skillshare Skillshare is an online
learning platform with over 20,000
classes in business design technology
and more you can take classes in social
media marketing data science mobile
fighter photography and creative writing
you name it they've got it it's the top
ten classes that this past weekend
listeners have signed up for I'm not
going to name all Tim but I'm a name a
couple presentation essentials how to
share ideas that inspire action sketch
sketch for beginners and designing your
own app how to make Android apps trap
music production whether you're trying
to deepen your professional skill set or
start a side hustle or just explore a
new passion skill share is there to keep
you learning and thriving you can get
two months of skills share for just 99
cents that's right skill share is
offering this past weekend listeners two
months of unlimited access for over
20,000 classes just 99 cents why send
your kid to college when you can send
them to Skillshare comm slash Theo again
go to Skillshare dot-com slash Theo to
start your two months now today's
episode features a man who is swollen
with joy a man who's probably when you
think about men probably one of the top
maybe nine thousand men on planet earth
I bet he's a guy you may know him from
MADtv you may know him just from you
know people love this guy he's basically
a human Santa you know he's kind of the
season
South Pole Santa he's that sweaty bad
boy and he's known time after time from
different podcasts this is no joke the
first time he and I have ever really had
a conversation because we don't even
really know each other we just seen each
other in the hallway sometimes and you
got to see him in the hallway because
you got to go around him I mean really
it's his hallway and I'm just kind of
waiting at the corner for him to pass so
I can go down it ladies and gentlemen
one of the top nine thousand men I think
I said the big whitey himself that honky
don't mr. Will Sasso
[Music]
happy holidays I know it is you
celebrate Christmas or don't I do yeah
yeah I do
do you celebrate Christmas oh definitely
so this is a safe space to say Merry
Christmas oh you definitely can say that
here yeah I started saying it again yeah
me too
you know what [ __ ] people tell me you
have to say Happy Holidays no you say it
I say I say Merry Christmas Happy
Hanukkah
cuz that's kind of most people are
that's what's in the area yeah I don't
give a [ __ ] if you have like blonde hair
and a little and you know a tiny little
face I'll still say Happy Hanukkah to
you yeah I don't care yeah if you can't
even read when I was growing up but not
a lot of people could read like they can
now so you had to you know you couldn't
really send a lot of Christmas cards you
had to tell people you did you know get
him to their face yes you know like in
our area we didn't really grow up like
in the you know Reading area I guess of
the US or some parts I grew up in like
kind of like a site like the non Reading
area yeah more like a non verbal bill
and we had I mean I remember one of our
teachers tried to only teach us they
only had 18 letters in the alphabet
where you were
are we going yeah well I don't know are
we it's just the Theo show we are
welcome to this past weekend guys we got
Will Sasso what's up one of the probably
top two or three hundred men in America
maybe yeah yeah I made the well this
past year I was in the just edged out of
the top 200 but I was in the top 300
million America yeah and who do people a
lot of times who beats you out for that
like is there a guy you're always
neck-and-neck well yeah there's a guy
named well there's a guy named Dale fuzz
lives in Kentucky oh yeah who he's a
school bus driver and he's a man and he
him and I go back and forth a lot we got
a lot of the same type of man I didn't
see that d fuzz dude and bus 161 well
the bus Charles will get that horn the
horn from a rig you know put in a bus
put in the bus or if you're in Dale's
case he has one of those just this sort
of thing so he can work this arm because
he's also the high school football coach
Oh
oh yeah the tails got it like that and
we both like smoked meats and so we kind
of go back and forth and meet him Kevin
James oh wow yeah I could see that
hovering around that 200 mark yeah yeah
I'm always fighting for 200 in in men's
magazine man magazine top 200 men okay
you're kind of a bigger guy if I look I
don't know I don't know if I'm reading
there named it seemed like he all
weekend II sighs I'm about 165 pounds
really right now no no I'm about 160 570
pounds or you saving up weight for
something yeah yeah I'm gay I'm getting
ready for the four I'm playing the day
I'm in the dáil fuzz story oh yeah
that's pretty cool it's independent so
we'll see who else is any what happens
well Dale fuzz has a cameo yeah yeah old
house playing he's playing a bus driver
oh yeah yeah so that'll be fun and it's
me him Toni Collette oh yeah
Harlan Williams Harlan Williams okay
yeah you read The Hollywood Reporter
Garry Buscemi Gary Buscemi who finally
gets a role after all these years ya
know being in the shadows little brother
Steve so it's gonna be a good it's gonna
be a good flick yeah yeah I can see that
man is there a movie that you wanted to
be in that you were that you that you
weren't in uh I probably would well I
was a little maybe it was a little
before my time but I kind of I like to
like you know I'll watch Apocalypse Now
and think that Marlon Brando was pretty
good in that role but I could be look at
her oh I don't know would have been 1 or
2 or not quite an embryo I could see you
in coach have you ever seen coach the TV
show yeah yeah I loved that show
actually yeah it wasn't one of my
favorite shows but I could always walk
watch it yeah yeah that was watchable TV
yeah it's gone a little bit on the
wayside man yeah the path the first like
25 years of that show were good the past
17 18 years yeah the first first quarter
century there's coach right there coach
yeah did you ever meet that guy uh no
what's his name again
Dale Vincent I think Dale Hansen clip
that is Craig T Nelson Craig T Nelson
never met
no I've never met Craig T Nelson Wow and
the other fellow is is Jerry Van Dyke
dick Van Dyke's brother
is it really yeah the the guy at the
older fella I met Dick Van Dyke at The
Comedy Store one really yeah he was like
140 years old his name
yeah that's Jerry Van Dyke Wow yeah and
yeah Dick Van Dyke isn't me
I follow he is amazing I follow him or
his wife on Instagram or Twitter I can't
remember and I I mean that to say he
doesn't post but his wife post [ __ ] of
him on his behalf which is amazing yes
this is Rob Petri for [ __ ] sake yeah
Petrey you know if you think of the old
Dick Van Dyke Show
guys been around for a hundred years and
he's like and she just shoots little
videos of him like dancing and cracking
jokes and he's [ __ ] more entertaining
than he's already hot he's on the top
100 manless they see a pretty hot lady
is she pretty huh yeah I think if you're
a hundred year old man not that you know
I don't wanna be ageist and I'm sure he
could probably you know yeah it does
very well with the ladies
what's wrong with Chris D'Elia do you
think because that's wrong with Julia
[ __ ] I don't know if we have enough time
ah if you had to pick six things do cuz
I don't wanna be mean six things yeah
let me just say right now I'm keeping
the sanehat on but it's hot as [ __ ] in
here it's not that hot what happened you
said you were burning a candle Oh what
happened well we had every in here with
Tourette's syndrome and that has nothing
to do with a lot of heat also you don't
know how to wear clothes you it may be
cooler yeah I do not know if I learned a
little bit if I learned a thing or two
about wearing clothes do look black is a
hot hot that's all I wear that's all I
[ __ ] work well right there I like to
keep it hot you can finally got a lot of
heat hibernating now what temperature
does your body run at you think ooh I
don't know if you ever suit have you
ever taken a steak and done a sous-vide
on a steak okay so Suzanne well well
it's it's basically just preheating the
the fats and the meats together you put
it in a sous-vide bag and you can even
get a special sous-vide pot and then you
hang the little steak over in there and
it just sort of essentially when you
take it out of there you could eat it
like that
is it good well then you throw it on the
grill so then the inside so you don't
have a steak that or the insides cold
but you're outside of me if you're me
you like it Chicago or Pittsburgh style
oh you charred on the outside rare on
the inside I get Pittsburgh's out a
little bit of pink guy on the edge yep
that pink guy that rippled that balloon
not inside so and then so if you do the
sous-vide and then you throw it on the
grill or in your pan yeah then and so
the outsides all so a sous-vide is about
180 degrees Fahrenheit maybe 881 so yeah
I can just like you know sit I'll sit I
could just put a steak between my legs
on the mom what is wrong with Julia uh
now he's good wait hold on let's think I
guess let's think well what's wrong with
brain ah Brom Bryan Callen yeah Brian's
strong for a little guy cut for like an
older guy yeah he is he's a very strong
16 year old man he has to be worrying
about existence you know yeah yeah he
must be worrying about his mortality I'm
43 years old and I have those sort of
things where I'm like oh I'm staring at
mortality going I literally shouldn't
eat that cuz I could go to sleep and not
wake up again really well why not why
not crazier things have happened
and what are like what kind of items are
those that you're you know that you have
like you know you're having those you
know kind of dining fears oh well if I
have like you know some of my pals over
we're just gonna hang out order a pizza
mm-hmm
watch a movie seems innocent enough I'll
look at that you know third or fourth
slice of pizza and that'll be the
that'll be the waypoint for me that'll
be the so you know you gotta turn it
down does it feel weird walking over to
a pizza box for the fifth slice does it
feel weird walking over to the pizza box
for a fifth no I think if you're I think
once you get past three then you're not
worried about your own if you're worried
if you think about your own mortality
and pizza then every walk to the pizza
box so really should be should be yeah
but then your friends leave when there's
those one or two slices left and what
are you doing I'm gonna throw them away
would you
I don't know you don't want to throw
them out in the back what's wrong with
the Leon gallon oh yeah pizza ignore
[ __ ] just like you I bet you
just don't give a [ __ ]
I haven't eaten this year I bet you're
one of those [ __ ] that has like
a pizza box in their fridge
eat that it's old old you dick it's been
in there
that shit's been in there a week and you
didn't eat it I'm gonna force you to eat
it now yeah there's guys that really
wild man you guys are [ __ ]
hey do we don't even know each other no
we don't really know each other and it's
awesome to be here to actually this is
the most actually your your audience is
witnessing the most that we've spoken
the every other as as far as this goes
yeah once we're finished this will be
like a thousand percent more yeah I've
ever spoken to each other yeah we've
really only seen each other through
Brendan and Brian over yeah and Chris
and you so you are a MADtv or an improv
artist I know that yeah you know just
acting on you know stuff yeah do you
feel were you always an actor were you
always like uh um were you always like a
class clown or what were you like what
was because some people get in a you
know comedy there class clowns some
people you know they're writers and they
think of it some people you know come at
it from more of like a creative space
like what was some of your stuff I was a
class clown really knew a class class I
was but just verbally I didn't do any
you know I wouldn't you know doing
anything physical
what do you mean I would just verbally
say something like you know like
somebody like my mom died like this each
one times like my mom died you know and
I was like prove it you know but I would
never get up and like you know juggle or
show my [ __ ] or like that yeah well
classic films I don't know if showing
your [ __ ] when we were kids when I
mean I've got some years on you but
generationally speaking when we were
younger it was okay to get up stand on
your desk and show your [ __ ] oh yeah
that would have been funny now you're
gonna have problems because it's just a
bunch of people we had to do mr. Patrick
he would give you 20 40 bucks he'd walk
about 60 feet from you show you his
[ __ ] long as you looked at he you
kept the money that's [ __ ] amazing
you know and is that bad a feeling I
don't know what that is
that's art that's art yeah as an ATM
dude yeah that's amazing
let's ask to money dude you know but
yeah and as long as he would only look
he'd kind of look back once to make sure
you were locked in dude and I didn't
feel like it you know I didn't like
watching him take his belt off but I
didn't
seeing his [ __ ] from far away gives
the [ __ ] it's just another man's [ __ ]
at that point back then pedophiles were
pedophile oh yeah you knew if it was a
pedophile yeah they had a van they were
yelling them uh pedophile yeah that's
right I'm a pedophile but a guy shown
his [ __ ] from 60 feet away yeah what
is that be kind of hard to [ __ ] with
that in court
yeah how far away was he 60 feet
prosecution how far away it wasn't a
different time look at the security
footage do we add it dude I remember in
the woods and we thought he was armed he
said he was a private investigator he
was a peeping tom really out there for
like two months yeah and finally like oh
this dudes just looking at everybody's
ass through the windows and nuts at
night right this dude is just out here a
hunting single mom [ __ ] nipple at
night yeah you view if you had a camera
on him late at night you see him prying
his [ __ ] open to no one we had a guy
see I grew up in a small town outside
Vancouver oh wow you're Canadian yeah
I'm from Canada and it was awesome kind
of a country-ass town called Ladner
beautiful beautiful place surrounded by
like there's the water on this side from
the Fraser River and then it's just all
farmland so we were water's cold huh oh
yeah yeah we cool not in the summer yeah
no swimming but you wouldn't want to
swim anyway it's great yeah but yeah I
think I out there in Pittsburgh yeah you
like that state naga halen oh dude and
bloody guy got a blow job he was it used
to be the Pittsburgh parrot he got a
blow job in an abandoned swimming pool
on the south side in an empty swimming
pool friend of mine anyway in Pittsburgh
no but we're talking about laughs I
would have loved if that story just
ended with my friend my buddy got a blow
job yeah anyway go ahead so uh yeah
Ladner was this sort of country town and
we there was a pedophile oh yeah his
name was Albert something oh yeah and it
was in Harbor Park where there was a
bunch of just feral bunnies and rabbits
and hares and jack rabbits and [ __ ] you
and he what he was in there in a tent
you know as as
the the Lord icked ated and if you went
in there and got molested it was your
fault because there was one guy and he
was in this [ __ ] don't go in Harbor
Park towards sunset you know that's what
we're doing it yeah that's where it's
all happening because it was a more
innocent time and I'll tell you right
now I can't think of anything off the
top of my head but if a teacher or you
know an educator of any kind pride his
[ __ ] open from 60 feet away in Ladner
British Columbia in the 1980s early 90s
I don't think anyone would have given a
[ __ ] yeah I don't think anybody would
have either I don't think anybody still
cares really does anybody really care or
is it just people want to be like you
know
yeah that's evil person yeah I want to
feel better about themselves yes people
yeah yeah yeah yeah absolutely that's
sort of that's you know that's what's
going on today if we had a dude who used
to give you he had like just he'd always
have raisins in his pockets individual
raisins and he'd give you a couple of
them we had to do my dad had a friend
and uh he'd put cinnamon on the [ __ ]
palm of his hand and let you lick it off
and this was probably and in one of his
feet was longer than the other one or he
had up what the [ __ ] is the network
extra foot he was black where we had
like half of an extra foot so you know
but at the bottom of it well Mike you've
always trying to show off you know but
he have I got no hold on a second he had
like a lift on his shoe one of his feet
wasn't that long feet oh I thought you
meant heels I had like two feet stacked
like a sandwich
no like a foot sandwich Oh sandwich get
a two-storey oh yeah - sorry foot oh my
goodness just a stack just a bigmac foot
um two patties hey what temp so what
city are you near near New Orleans okay
so that's [ __ ] up
yeah well I mean we had regular people
around here but my dad had this dude
this guy and he would just pay him to
kind of stand around us sometimes and he
um yeah he always had a little bit of
cinnamon in his Hannum this one I was
young not if now there's cinnamon
anywhere there's Vietnamese cinnamon
there's [ __ ] you know you could be to
send them out of a [ __ ] Korean if you
hit him hard enough yeah they're guys
they got some in their pockets I'm not
believing any [ __ ] trellis I'm saying
everybody's keeping everybody's got some
say now everybody's keeping secrets and
a lot of people kind of I would imagine
a lot of people out of your view
and listeners you know kind of go like
well what is the you know what's the
secret like what's going on in Hollywood
cuz they think like it doesn't matter
how how you people like you or me get it
come across people they always think
we're hiding something yeah and that's
what I have to say to your audience
especially the young people out there if
you beat the [ __ ] out of someone hard
enough you'll get that cinnamon oh yeah
and that could be I could be speaking in
metaphor or we could be speaking quite
literally about you know your friend
with the cinnamon in the palm yeah I
mean we could be talking I'm talking a
spice work yeah so you never know but I
looked it I've always been really fond
of Canadians and they've grown on me
over time you know and I wouldn't mind
in the next life or if things get a
little hairy here a little more hairier
in the u.s. I could move up to Canada I
know a lot of people that are talking
about it 100% not to Leah or Kalin
that's another thing wrong with them
they don't like Canadians that's crazy
I've never told them that I'm Canadian
is really and all the time that we go
yeah I never thought you would be
Canadian man you seem like a guy that
wouldn't be Canadian but now I'm not
surprised what you did tell me what is
it about me that you think is Canadian
what is it you just seem a little more
kindred than man American you know okay
you seem to have a more of a good nature
more of like at peace with yourself a
little bit more Americans they seem a
lot more like just volatile and
unsettled you know okay
yeah people usually say are you Canadian
or from Chicago yeah I could see that
people think I'm from Chicago cuz I'm a
bigger fella and I'm in comedy yeah yeah
that's kind of if I look at this guy
right here out of Wisconsin is Farley
right there and he got and did you ever
do drugs and alcohol no no I never got
into well I drank I could drink like a
like a piece of [ __ ] with my buddies you
know growing up I actually haven't had a
drink in a long time but I just recently
about a year ago reintroduced some red
wine oh yeah I hadn't I hadn't had a
drink in like six years but I never III
now I know I know that you you you
you've gone through the yeah I don't
drink yeah and I I agree with that as a
matter of fact I got there just kind of
you know I never really it wasn't
something that I did too often drinking
so it wasn't like oh I need to stop this
for you know any of the
the reasons that you know a lot of
people you weren't having trouble and
wasn't having trouble I just it just
didn't agree with me I feel like it
doesn't agree with me I feel like it
doesn't agree with anybody it really is
[ __ ] weird it's sort of socially
accepted it's a drug that's so socially
accepted because I mean you know
whatever we could talk about things
old-fashioned I'm starting to think a
little bit of it's old-fashioned
especially nowadays I see everybody is
using arm mushrooms magic mushrooms yeah
absolutely
or you know whatever you know the [ __ ]
that comes from the earth and whatever
your opinion is on that you know that
you know certainly things like marijuana
or you know I've never done mushrooms or
anything but it's like [ __ ] comes from
the earth and and you think about like
alcohol goes through this all this
different process whether you're brewing
or distilling danver half of it goes
through Denver mill walk yeah it has to
go through Milwaukee or Denver and then
you have like Scott Elliot going because
it's the water in Colorado all that
course has to go through taller the
Rocky Mountain wick coolers the banquet
beer and that's pretty good
yeah it needs work let me try man yeah
course the bank would be yeah you sound
like Scott Elliot just woke up is this
Scott Elliot who's scott ali he's the
guy with the mustard do you have to use
so many curse words Oh Sam Elliot what
did I say Scott Elliot yeah see that's
I'm doing a perfect Scott Elliot
it's his younger brother Halle Jerry Van
Dyke why am I doing this what I have a
mustache what somebody got their cut off
and just put installed right there you
just go into a lab and have your finger
cut off and so do your thing
oh is this it you can play strong-willed
you do it your own way when your
uncompromising second fest never crosses
your mind when you're set in your ways
you stay true to yourself you can
contribute to them you have too many
animals how many animals do you have I
got really the only dude you got a
family or not no you know something's
going on then what's going on because
it's starting to seem kind of weird yeah
it is starting to seem kind of weird
even though we've only known each other
through this podcast it's immediately
weird when you're like 43 year old man
you're dressed like a kid yeah
I'm wearing a Santa hat good mustache
Who am I now you wanna lick my palm
course the bank would be like my beer
yes your honor I did show those children
my [ __ ]
but I was 60 feet away course you know
enough tours will make you do those new
we used to have a lot of gays would meet
up behind a rest area bar in our town
you know because I grew up across a
river from a rest area uh-huh and ought
to have rest area Encana rest area in
America it's where you stop on the
interstate truck and truck drivers yet
drugs kill a spouse leave a kid you know
I'm saying it's basically it's like a
halfway house but it's unincorporated
you know and that's a good way to stay
had a lot of the gay you know homoerotic
men sorry would meet up behind there and
do drugs and start touching each other
not even necessarily homosexual just
homoerotic yeah cuz a lot of this was
drug induced yeah it was a guy like Dale
fuzz he gets a bunch of those like
Spanish Fly or [ __ ] stay up all night
baggies at the gas station and then
pretty soon fuzz is like you know dude I
met a girl in Miami over by Joe's Crab
Shack and bought nine of those gas
station you know dick pills is when they
first came out bro put in 1986 I
couldn't pin my fingers right there was
no is up all my fingers
any of them and I would go through each
one and try to bend them you're lucky to
be alive and it's [ __ ] moe dude on my
nose is bleeding I musta lost
how much you know how much blood I lost
that night but but anyway but that was
the first time I've had snow crab I
remember that yeah it's a good thing you
remember that even though your brain was
bleeding you hung on to that lovely
memory but they had one time me and my
buddy going the woods we had my buddy
Jeremy we go in the woods and add two
dudes out there shooting potatoes with
one of those slingshots across the river
nice if gay guys would get together and
start making out if they were on drugs
if they're just gay guys meeting up
having a picnic
that's no harm no foul how would you
know cuz they'd have like a little
Christmas a little picnic no these guys
knew it was tell if they were two dudes
on [ __ ] methamphetamines yeah
wouldn't normally so basically they were
do it they felt like they were doing a
an anti homoerotic service by saying you
don't really want to have sex with that
guy
yeah I'm saving your marriage yeah now
what even funny I think if they'd had
done sweet potatoes you know because I
think that would have kind of added like
a cute thing yeah and the guy we get hit
me i but but i think they wanted to
prevent sexually transmitted diseases
yeah coming to their town you [ __ ]
coming to the rest stop you draw you
[ __ ] you infect everybody with your
disease and then you roll on you're a
bunch of frozen chicken you're the [ __ ]
out of here yeah and we have to deal
with it in our town yeah they were doing
a public service you got a bunch of her
pee you know spotted up Tyson cut let's
see you're rolling on yeah yeah you're
doing 95 miles an hour with 6000 pounds
on [ __ ] in the chicken [ __ ] [ __ ]
dirty chicken
yeah there's no regulation at all yeah
we're here with these [ __ ] potatoes
because they've got a bunch of these in
a field behind us you ain't come and
locally brother on our watch no not here
so that was it was kind of a different
time I don't know where we're talking
about but um but yeah it was just a
different time and but it was a
different time it was like you know
people could enjoy themselves a little
more oh sure yeah back then well now
especially I mean you look at how things
are changing exponentially every time I
read a story every time I sort of get
into it into the you know whatever
there's so many manner of things that
are changing rapidly and we're two white
dudes
so when you when you who kind of go like
oh well here's what's going on
you know socially whether it's a
regional thing like what happens here in
California whether it's a gender thing
which is you know all over the country
and and most parts of the Western world
what's what's changing and how how fast
it's changing I can't even believe or
you'll you'll see some things now there
you go like that was 2016 and you feel
like so much has changed
Wow i I'm curious you know as a stand-up
does that because I was listening to
something with like anyway well I'll ask
you because I was listening I was
watching this thing on YouTube and some
stand-ups were talking about it has it
affected you and what you do you know I
think I looked at an old set from like
eight years ago or something I was on
Comedy Central and I don't think I felt
weird about having it up still ah yeah
so that was interesting but I also
noticed that like like I'll go on things
like JK news if you've been on their
show no it's um it's a good show and
they're all diversity and [ __ ] who
knows bro it's so mixed over there you
can't even you know it's basically might
as well be in a war fifty years ago you
know everybody's it's pretty diverse so
anyway you're over there and they talk
about all the funnest stuff they talk
like we used to talk fifteen years ago
well I kind of feel like it's only
Hollywood and these are LA people these
are Latinos Koreans Asians they don't
know they have fun and it's often on
show to be on they're not minding their
P's and Q's no it's only when I get into
like this side of the tracks yeah
Hollywood side yeah we're team well you
know and and whatever I mean I mean I'm
not the first to say this but you know
it is a lot of white guilt there's a lot
of white just white people or people who
are of the I don't even know what you
would I don't even know how you would
label the culture outside of saying just
PC or you could say like you know lefty
or whatever the [ __ ] you want to say
Hollywood left whenever that are you
know that are mostly changing that when
you think about just being able to cut
loose regardless of what line you're
what side of the line you're on it feels
like I mean when I got here to LA it was
like
there was no [ __ ] problem you could
say what uh oh yeah [ __ ] you wanted and
we should do [ __ ] on MADtv I couldn't
believe what we were doing I was you
know like a young dude and I showed up
I'm like can we can we say that and you
know and then pretty soon you get your
feet wet and you're good about this and
and it was it was great because people
still still got along and everything but
it's hard to deny you know it's it's you
of course want to listen to everybody's
take and you of course ya don't want I
you know I've never wanted to do comedy
to hurt anyone's feelings as a matter of
fact I kind of left MADtv going I'm not
even comfortable making fun of [ __ ]
celebrities anymore Wow cuz well not
like making fun like if there's
something even if there was something to
make fun of if there's some sort of
scandal I was like like I would do like
you know my impersonations and [ __ ] or
anything that was specifically targeted
at celebrities I would always try to
make it silly and stupid and yeah what
about any real yeah didn't want to do
the stuff that was that was you know
pointedly mean so but that's just me and
and so of course I want to pay attention
to I don't think that comedy should
exist to make people feel bad right I
think it should do the opposite so you
can't help but but or I can't help but
kind of pay attention to people who are
like well that's [ __ ] out and that
hurts people's feelings I'll listen to
that [ __ ] all day long I'm already not
very offensive
yeah very offensive at all and most of
the work I do most of the [ __ ] that I'm
doing 9:00 to 5:00 is acting anyway yeah
I mean right chica burger yeah you know
it's behind it but nowadays the stuff
that if I'm if I'm working on some
creating something and developing
something it's like it comes in - yeah
it comes into my mind but it's it's uh
oh I see you got it but podcast you can
still say it on some do you feel like
that yes I think mostly because of the
way podcasts are set up no one's really
gonna go through I mean right now it's
still the while nobody's really gonna
listen to them no one's gonna listen to
an hour and a half of a facade cast and
pick out the and I actually was
listening to I was watching something
that was making me laugh which is the
dumbest setup to say someone it was ours
I was watching something that was
me left yes Ozark no I was just watching
some the second seasons not as funny not
as funny as the first season
it's like coach the end of the first
season with that electric boat did you
see that one um no what happened in that
am I forgetting how to wear clothes
again I don't know
damn dude yeah you look like a usually
you'll get a panda bear that is
definitely been doing crime I'm not
gonna go steal funny bamboo out of the
air one like it looks like I own the
market you look like a dude Voldemort
but that word that goes shopping at a
market all the time
fold the market no I was just watching
something and then one guy called the
other guy like a gay slur but he they
were really angry at each other and it
made me laugh so [ __ ] hard because it
it it's like it made me laugh that
nowadays it makes me laugh because half
of it is like oh you can't what are you
doing you can't [ __ ] say that and and
then the other half is like damn back in
the day we used to say whatever the [ __ ]
we wanted Wow and you would it's like
you would even call people [ __ ] that I
mean you want to talk about calling
people [ __ ] that technically they're not
would you what makes it funny
I mean you could call people anything
now you can't but also I kind of feel
like the woke missus is coming from
people look at the history and they go
look this is just my opinion I don't
think people that aren't black shouldn't
be saying the n-word
I think the black people say the n-word
and it's their word to own and they can
do whatever the [ __ ] they want with it
white people shouldn't say that word by
that logic there's a bunch of [ __ ] that
people who are not should not say right
so if it's something that can become a
different term between you know within
that community
whether it's you know the gay community
or the black community or whatever they
get to govern that's just that's just me
but that's that's a societal opinion
right my own opinion there are no
[ __ ] rules
we had a guy we you know we got a guy
coming up on an episode that has
Tourette's and he was telling me how you
can't even have Tourette's these days
because you write Tourette's
you can't even have a disease Tourette's
is offensive dude yeah
he said he's got a lot of young dudes
hitting him up with Tourette's and
asking him how to best you know hide the
end where the pee yells it out of date
you know out of Ramada or something if
you're have been a Ramada it's hard to
not you know drop it a couple times you
know saying they're gonna be if they got
all kinds a crime on the at those places
I was watching a thing I was what
there's a clip online if you think about
that you can't even have a disease
anymore you can't have Tourette's you
know you can barely be from Nicaragua
you know what do you mean without
offending somebody you know you better
say it clear and pronounce the CE o you
know and that's right that's right
absolutely right I mean it's just a
different time I'm not even gonna get
into some of the African countries oh
dude she brought order than nigiri bro
yeah yeah that's right playing gang you
said Jeff instead of yes safe you are
okay um you gotta be safe because you
gotta say that and train your tongue so
that you can get the nigiri sushi I have
two pieces of salmon nigiri look I don't
even same injury I used to say misery
misery is good too anything to get you
away yeah you do these are social things
it's all for us to decide there are no
pointed rules I mean who are we gonna
listen to you make up your own so if you
want to say nigiri but do you think
though that people start like now though
like uh it's funny cuz a lot of times
the only people that are allowed to be
safely made fun of on television anymore
like poor white people yeah and that's
where I'm from and that's what makes me
mad cuz it's like will [ __ ] you it's
it's way hard to be poor what about rich
white people and to me the only people
that still even own black people or own
anybody in the world anymore
er executive producers or people that
own the rights to people yeah you know
like if you want to look it that's the
only ownership going on anymore you know
if you want to look at like that guy
who's on that The Cosby Show he's out
there you know stack and [ __ ] you
know little wonk quantum little quantum
uh um kumquats and then they're saying
oh you don't have any money
somebody's making money off of them
being on TV every week Jeffrey right you
know a white guy with Bill Cosby which
one you talking to free Owens Jeffrey
Jeffrey Owens I always get a million I
only only remember half of the people's
names yeah
I like that yeah Jeffrey oh you mean the
Olympian yeah you mean Daniel Klaus know
this guy Brad Trump hey guys what's
going on with grad Trump you think
Mexicans should be deported how about
that haircut of yours Brad Trump I don't
know what happened I went out there I
gave him my Bradshaw I got really good
stuff on Brad Trump and nobody know it's
that you said you do they have what kind
of um evil do they have in Canada that
they don't have in America do you think
beavers
oh yeah about that yeah we got we got
cats like I was dating a girl she had
two cats and I couldn't imagine if she
had two beavers of it yeah that's [ __ ]
up because when you're in Canada and
you're just like dating a girl or me you
know you know it's like it'd be nice to
settle down with a knight with a nice
Canadian gal as I look as I look forward
but a lot of times I'll get you know
I'll meet someone on the you know I'll
be home for a while or something or even
when I'm fortunate enough to get to work
up there and you know and you meet a
girl and it's like oh this is going good
and [ __ ] and then you finally get back
to her place and she has two rabid
beavers oh yeah
and you go to sleep like if it's like
[ __ ] goes alright and then you go to
sleep and then you want to use the
bathroom in the middle of night and you
get up and all your clothes and shoes
and [ __ ] are all stacked up by the
bathroom door has made a dam and you
can't even [ __ ] get in there and
you're like yeah it's really [ __ ] up
right yeah you can't do [ __ ] and what
about the Iditarod what happened with
that because you guys are doing that
with the dog we got the dogs yeah and
why are they doing that tradition I
guess you know hey you know I shot a
film in the Arctic and Wow
yeah it was nuts outdoors no I was in a
studio but it cost less to go to just
went out there to shoot on this town it
sounds - yeah Arctic Arctic Studios I
thought you were with it BAM Santa's
doing working office isn't he they shot
all the Wolverines oh yeah
so no so we went over in the Arctic and
you know I'm from Canada they kind of
you know we have more of a you know you
grow up you sort of learn what they want
you to learn about our First Nations
people and stuff but I realized how
ignorant I was because that snow
sledding [ __ ] the dog sleds that they
they don't have like they don't have
roads that go from town to town in the
Arctic it's just like here's a town and
the only way to get anywhere else is by
plane or when the ocean is frozen that's
what they're [ __ ] they're sledding on
and I realized just how [ __ ] it was
crazy and of course everyone was so nice
and just sweet they're so you they would
say like hey we're gonna go over here to
our friends cabin on snowmobiles or
wolf-like sled dogs let's and like you
want to come
and I'm like no there's gonna be
brothers Alcor yeah or yeah
Falkor would be a good way to get around
the Arctic that's so you really went to
the Arctic yeah you shocked by it yeah a
lot of things shocked me about it
it was it was crazy it was it was it was
awesome it was a very interesting place
there's definitely a magnet in there we
were in this town
Calla wit which is the capital of
Nunavut which is the Inuit territory up
there known if it Inuit none of it like
it was it was a lot of you want nothing
to do it was it was gnarly
but there was like cool [ __ ] like this
dude Madi own this [ __ ] BBQ joint and
he was flight from Quebec so he had like
a legit barbecue plays with like you
know they were had you know had all
sorts of you know Sam and all kinds of
stuff
yeah but they also had like beef and
[ __ ] he was flying it in and and he let
me borrow a minivan for a while yeah do
you think do a lot of people sometimes
when I see people in Canada it seem like
they don't have anything to talk about
well that's because you're American so
they don't want to talk to you about all
the Canadian stuff yeah I could be a I
could be a liaison into Canada for you a
lot of your example a lot of people in
Canada a lot of people think that
Canadians are polite not true there's a
lot of [ __ ] Canadians Wow but they'd
only show themselves as like a Navy and
[ __ ] to other Canadians
actually and this isn't this is actually
well-documented I think like they say
people in the South so you can confirm
or deny like the whole like you know
they'll be like nice to your face but
then he'll bless her heart it's this and
that so that this sort of that's
Canadian we have that in common
we're you know and I mean people are
shitty everywhere but I think that's
specific it's it's been said a lot of
Canadians like oh it's kind of like the
the the sort of sweet part of the South
where people are just like oh hello how
are you very proper yeah and then behind
your back they'll say also and they got
vivo doo-dah land or so they got a
matinee dolls yeah yeah you could just
get them at the airport any of those
things just like a little like beaver at
all it's actually a Canadian voodoo doll
don't be fooled do you do you feel like
um hot yeah it's a little warm you were
burning a candle in here yeah we had a
gal tourettes in here too and he left a
lot of heat in the room right there
[ __ ] human furnaces like the Amish
make them they're [ __ ] it's Mesmer I
would imagine so there's just a lot
churning and burning going on running at
104 degree I mean you think of all the
curse words just milling her man in
their body trying to get out they could
sous-vide a steak you oh dude a guy cut
his oh he cut his wrist and a couple of
n-bombs fell out you know I'm [ __ ]
they're wild animals yeah dude let's
talk about the strap this is last year's
strap yes okay how do you feel
let me get a little hold it out sucker
bra been collected us cuz I've had it
for so long it is a beautiful piece of
his a beautiful beautiful strap 162
dollars and had to pay for myself so
like getting a star on the Walk of Fame
they're like congratulations give us
eight grand yeah I turned them down
several times this is amazing
yeah that's it man do you think you have
a shot at this year's uh won't let me
tell you something no I don't know I
don't figure do with your stirring
rendition of this how we do it yeah this
is how we do it that I don't know what
the [ __ ] that was Friday night Friday
night is I get a calendar
who's saying that dude somebody with a
cheap calendar this is how we do it it's
interesting Wednesday it's Wednesday
night it would never would have never
gone down as day and what a poor truck
stop firing sweet potatoes you're not
really gay
cheating on your wife with another dude
cuz you're high on dick pills
drug-induced almost like you're a latane
I figures can't bend then your nose is
bleeding
I think it's I I think it's between I
think it's between you and Chris I don't
we talking about I think God think the
LEAs got it
well D'Elia has a [ __ ] I mean he has
an army here's an army mm-hmm Gus you
know
yeah it's called who gives a [ __ ] he has
a cold it's like I'm William Wallace you
know or not William Wallace I'm [ __ ]
I'm Wayne Wallace you know Wayne Wallace
couple of brothers and a couple of eight
bad Asian [ __ ] helping me out on the
side Wayne Wallace we got a couple of
bad [ __ ] right here my boy Petey
right here [ __ ] turn this that's good
thank you
I've done Scottish before that's that's
goddess right I think it is he always
does
he has 9 legs bro yeah it's easy to do
comedy when you have 9 [ __ ] legs
piece of [ __ ] oh my goodness I didn't
say piece of [ __ ] they edited that in
yeah that happens as technology dude and
then they got this new ginger guy up
there yeah
cheeto is his name or whatever getting
the [ __ ] out of here bro if your parents
loved you to give you a decent anything
that's actually this is named cheeto I
don't know yeah where I'm from dude you
don't even listen to those guys till
they're 40
you know redheads yeah ya know you got a
you got a get with the program for you
pipe up yeah I'm saying you little
cinnamon stick you have to approve some
wisdom that's ready before you start
pretty sure Aaron just ideas yeah yeah
you better be that who's that
[ __ ] from like Revenge of the
Nerds and thirtysomething don't worry
about it this is before Timothy Busfield
Timothy we didn't really listen to
Timothy Busfield before he turned about
40 years old now he direct from Baton
Rouge
Timothy bus I've 11 yeah about 5 8 5 5
11 - I know I know urban based life this
guy died Timothy Busfield on their diet
really yeah oh I know Timothy but I
don't know him that's still alive do we
should link their families oh oh that
would be cool uh yeah IIIi uh guess who
it is
it's Timothy Timothy Busfield and you
open it it's a different wine and he's
like yeah that's a great idea
that is a good idea that could be a show
it could be a good show what would it be
called you think [ __ ] no no dude I
think named that [ __ ] would be a good
thing like the tea to show his [ __ ]
where you have people from your past and
they line up 60 feet away yeah and and
spread their they [ __ ] pull their
their meat apart and you get to like
look right down the center I could name
policies now I think I could name two
from a maybe six feet I there was a
picture of me of my [ __ ]
and I didn't I couldn't recognize it oh
wow a friend of mine had a bunch of like
speaking of [ __ ] you used to do I guess
the guys were all hanging out one thing
led to another and I was like mooning
one of my friends who was like passed
out in the chair
from drinking too much problem that's
all I feel like that's a propose yeah
yeah but no I'm moving your buddies
seems like you know that's like a
Canadian Bar Mitzvah yeah yeah that's
how with you yeah even if you're a
redhead you're a man and I just remember
I I it was we were like I was like
mooning it was me
oh wow and so so this picture this is
like a couple years back my buddy's like
hey check out these old pictures I had
developed and like went because he had
like one of those disposable cameras oh
what's in this from the 90s and he looks
at it and it's and there's a picture and
I I thought it was my buddy Outman I
thought it was a different dude I didn't
like that's not my ass yeah he's like
look and look at the thing in your head
and look at the shirt balinese yeah I'm
like oh wow so I'm like yeah that's me I
didn't recognize my own [ __ ]
impressive vast whiter than I thought it
would be yeah not as hairy as I thought
it wouldn't times though different times
though I mean a 25 year old [ __ ] like
my 25 year old [ __ ]
I'm sure it's bushy now much bushier
it's been 18 years since I haven't
looked at it haven't looked straight
into it Wow
the way I could with the developed
picture and nowadays you can't take that
picture and that's [ __ ]
hey now did you take that picture under
the service lady they're like all you're
a pedophile or you're a creep yeah you
know if there were still if there was
still photo developing places and you
brought that in yeah you'd be in you got
to get it your [ __ ] drawing now if
you really want to quality shot of it
yeah if you want if you want a beautiful
picture of your [ __ ] you'd have to
visit a portrait artist and they'd have
to probably sign an NDA what's next
after everybody doing but activities now
on the internet what's next do you think
what's the next orifice you know because
we're running out of spot yeah we're
running out of holes yeah with all the
body modifications [ __ ] we might come up
with new holes like Pierson new [ __ ]
we think yeah maybe like a new like a
like a hole actually that could kind of
solve a lot of problems now because with
you know you know when they talk about
like with regard to to gender and
pronouns and stuff if a lot of people
just had a hole drilled in their Gooch
between those yeah between their balls
in their ass hole
raped me along the median you know just
put something there in between yeah so
that we can all just sort of be one for
a while and then figure out maybe in
another heart he's not yeah a party spot
yeah you give it a nickname like a
little you know hole in the wall yeah
hole in the wall you could call it a
Donnie's last resort yeah
Donnie's last Dale Fuzz we could call it
a yeah sweet potato yeah sweet potatoes
good sweet potato sweet potato hole the
risotto
the risotto yeah yes the risottos garden
and you could call it whatever you want
and the Giri wiII be gone and the Giri
home do you do mr. risottos garden do
you think there's a time your life when
you're more obsessed with your body and
then it changes over time the a time
when you're more obsessed yeah I think
when you're like 13 or 14 and you beat
off for the first time you're like wow I
can do this all by myself
oh you think you're a magician yeah
that's an interesting time when you
realize you can beat up adults or at
least for me oh yeah by the time I was
like nine world old I was like yeah I
could beat up take any [ __ ] off of
anyone by the time I was like giant ten
year old chubby 10 year old couldn't
beat the [ __ ] out anybody did is it hard
being a big guide is it with some of the
downfalls of it well the only downfall
really is being hot as [ __ ] right now in
this hottest [ __ ] it's not so hot I'm
wearing this and I feel actually
comfortable you guys okay you know I
rotate I I get I'm bigger and I'm
smaller sometimes again it's all about
the my own my own view of mortality as
it relates to that fourth or fifth slice
of pizza I mostly ignore carbs so I stay
away from the carbs I'll just eat lots
and lots of meat
what is her a really meaty guy on yeah I
wouldn't be I was a vegetarian I've done
pescetarian mm-hm
but no I gotta have red meat and that's
not even my blood type Wow what else
would you like to know about me it's
interesting when did you get into
stand-up colbry I got in let me see 23
that's awesome
where
three four were you still living in
Louisiana where you here doing I was
living here yeah out here yeah I'm how
long wait when so you moved here before
you start doing stand-up yeah what did
you move here for mmm I don't know
here's what happened a friend of mine
lived in San Francisco and he's like hey
man come out and visit me so I went out
there and he's not you know both of us
are you know know you know you know see
women yeah and I went out there to hang
out with him and right when I get there
he's like hey dude I'm moving to Los
Angeles the day I get there look is it
get do I need help moving so basically
and then next thing you know I came to
Los Angeles with him me and he ended up
looking for a place he got a room and I
got a room 150 bucks I was sleeping
under his bed my buddy Kevin and I got
sick I got whooping cough actually so I
could barely even moved for like three
months dude it was very scary
I had whooping cough which is an ancient
disease and I got it your shots when you
were a kid
they don't do that I don't know dude
they somebody else probably got them you
know now is that somebody cutting in
line to get you dope over there you know
over in st. Tammany Parish dude you know
I knew one dude who got [ __ ] he would
never get a measles mumps or rubella bro
no I took everyone else oh yet four
gallons of [ __ ] anti-venom in them
you know you probably saved your life
yeah I've had some I've taken a lot of
those boy there's gas station uppers one
time I popped a couple in the gas
station forgot about it and got so sick
I couldn't leave the gas station for
like an hour and a half I to sit down in
one of the aisles do those things the
Rhino the ones with the rhinoceros on
I'm extremely dangerous yeah don't eat
anything with the rhinoceros anything
happened with gas station nigiri once
oh man you'll be sitting in the aisle
Junior's oh so you moved to LA right
away so then I was down here and I just
stayed man I stayed and I stayed for a
while they had a comedy club down the
street from my apartment on San Vicente
and I went in there they had one night a
week and I went in there and then yeah
just stayed I guess that's [ __ ]
awesome yeah cuz I would have thought
that you would have been I would have
thought you would have been one of those
kids who was like I mean you're saying
you were still you were a class clown
yeah
and I'm sure I don't know I think is
that you know I'm sure
you know people like this like I had
friends in my life where I'm like oh
this [ __ ] guy's so [ __ ] funny oh
yeah and he does this or that for a
living like guys buddies of mine back
home or something or friends out here
that aren't the business and I just like
does that person know that they're
[ __ ] and they could do it right so so
that's interesting to me because I would
have thought you would have been like
thinking about it when you were a kid
and go nah Wow I remember seeing it in
college one time I mean like people do
this Wow who is this guy Wow I thought
he was a leper something right so yeah
whatever that is I don't know what that
is and I thought yeah I remember going
and and going to a comedy club me like
wow it's crazy somebody can do this so
then I guess whenever I saw the place I
was like all you know I'll go in there
and I didn't think I was gonna be good
at this maybe to like about seven or
eight years when I was like oh you know
I can actually do you know I can do this
you know seven eight years in yeah Wow I
think I was still a lot of times
thinking about not doing it you know I
took a break about five years for about
six months and just when got a job
bartending in Louisiana I don't know you
know and then now it's like kind of a
full-time job of course so what were you
were you freaked out the first time you
went up for the first few times you
weren't I don't think so my dad was so
old my dad was 70 when I was born you
know I talked about that on stage so I
had like such a piece of material you
know that it was like undeniable you
know so like I knew I could get a couple
laughs after that I was scared I was so
scared to stray from anything that I
knew was comfortable sure sure sure um
and and I can't even imagine an improv
improv class I took I could never do
that
really Jesus Christ dude I think you got
to be Canadian do improv because you got
to be accepting of others and willing to
work with us well I never really did
like improv class or like it like really
yeah I didn't really come from the like
improv world like improvisational
theatre or anything you know you were
just an actor and then that's how you
got into well I always wanted to goof
around and [ __ ] I was a class clown and
I was like you know I wanted to I wanted
to do Renaissance Faire you ever do
Renaissance Faire yeah I wanted to do
Ren fairs you really yeah I want to be
when people do him a lot up there I want
to be the town
the Ren Faire did you really do it or
not no no is it Nick Swardson
termination that's a good but actually
it's not an explorer that is definitely
an exportation the Vikings
we're gonna [ __ ] lose I'm gonna diary
out of my [ __ ] at this bar come hang
out diary up that's Nick Swardson step
on dig for me tonight in Tirana
area now I'm gonna scour the internet
he's dressed up like Prince he has on
like 90 different colors of like lip
polish and he's like I'm out here okay
guys I'll be it Larsen's bar and diary
area and I'll be having you know you
guessed it farting Timon but come out go
bike skull any vomiting was own laugh
closer but it's funny though man he's a
great guy and everybody seems to really
love being around him you know he's a
really sweet he's a real sweet guy but I
think you know you got that wrong the
way you bother back you got huh you got
I think the league gets the belt next
year you know yeah I think the Lea gets
this he has the key as the people he can
get them to vote it's got a lot of Airy
large following on on the internet which
which is I don't have it well deserved I
mean not Chris is here's what I said
here's what I said to my dear friend
Chris not too long ago I said actually
do it now you've seen that [ __ ] that
dude the bleach bleach media leads me
yeah this dude has been making these
really funny videos using taken your
heads and our heads and like you know
but I remember a couple years ago saying
like Chris buy some [ __ ] land and do
it like start an actual cult you have
you have an l ron hubbard opportunity
here yeah to actually because his fans
are there's something other they're very
loyal and never and he he's writing
essentially writing a religion
yes [ __ ] CUDA [ __ ] yeah he's like
what is it oh I don't know uh I don't
know he was texting me we were texting a
British job impersonations who I mean
yeah I don't know I don't know be dude
were you gonna be Bry Oh don't need all
the chilies for I get there I'll be in
New Mexico in 16 months Oh should have
fought him yeah
oh is that a good fight for him yeah uh
I don't know yeah hey how about this
don't like that guy I don't know don't
fight that guy fight this other guy oh
maybe that would have been a better yeah
I do a marketing bro
black rifle coffee bean sounds like he's
got some weird you gonna debride I'll be
in Milwaukee you can it you can mix it
with Nick Swardson
oh yeah but I told ya I told the LIA
like start an actual cult you're you're
writing this stuff the CUDA alright like
I said we were texting and he goes he's
something I told them and I told them
that I ordered these shoes or whatever
and he was I was like I sent him a
picture of these shoes like cuz I you
know I have seven pairs of shoes right
yeah
he's got like you know assuming too many
shoes and so I was like I'll bug a
muggle like you know hey I ordered some
new New Balance you know the [ __ ] so
you can go [ __ ] those dad shoes
I ordered a pair of shoes and he was
like yeah you [ __ ] CUDA I was like
don't don't do that - don't say that to
me first of all I don't know what that
know what your dumb thing what does it
even mean
so so he sounds like a fat girl like
stuck in a wishing well you know and
they were white like a real big girl
stuck in a wishing well they throw a
ladder down to her and they're like
here's a ladder and it's like the little
bitty Aladdin she's like oh she's really
mad down there we gotta get a big bigger
ladder she's doing it so then he told me
what kuda means and then I said well uh
well then your [ __ ] you Yura kuda yeah
and he got really really upset upset he
goes no no I'm not take it back and I go
nope he is a coot is and I was like yo
you guys no I'm not I'm like whoa what
the [ __ ] is he you can't even tell me
what the [ __ ] it means then movie you're
a CUDA you're you're a [ __ ] you know
you're a dancer salmon I don't know all
these different you know a Mun a Mun
yeah not the first not Bera just kuda
not salmon the money money dude he's
like a leopard kind of that you know
isn't really being a leopard as do
another [ __ ] and kind of bothering
people
that's what I think well I would I would
like for him to bring out the leopard
because I know he's the romantic Jaguar
and I would like to remain a Jaguar
that's a good idea
yeah I'll watch that like six or seven
times but I I would like for him to
start an actual cult you know he doesn't
have to go like wild country style
doesn't have to be Oregon Colorado be
good spy he wouldn't even show up we'd
probably have a lanai yeah yeah that
[ __ ] guy who's basically a blood
donor for him the note she's basically
just like if Chris needs a kidney
it couldn't be about the comedy it's
gotta be about you know the guy is
decent plasma levels or whatever yeah I
was there no reason
he's right you know each carton that guy
around no yeah I would I would wet if I
were a betting man I'd say they have the
same blood type
yeah he got the note she checked out
like like what's her face did a big lip
oh I bet
da I think Chris could like worse bro if
Chris went if Chris had an actual call
yeah and he bought some land let's say
in the Arctic and he went up there like
every three months like four times a
year did a [ __ ] show show you know
showed his new [ __ ] and then people are
gonna be sitting there freezing cold out
there they're gonna be excited for when
he comes and I'm thinking dog sled
around he can send in videos and stuff
yeah you could send in videos hard to
download [ __ ] and the Arctic is it yeah
the yeah the Wi-Fi the internet speeds
are not very good I could see that yeah
but you know and then he could just come
out there every three months do some
stand-up and [ __ ] everybody yeah that
would be I mean that's what I'm saying
beat have a cult have a real well it is
it is what you join it or not I would be
I wouldn't mind you are just to join it
to I would all be men with a meet and
greet after I wouldn't mind being like a
high cardinal or something like that and
then like maybe turn on him Game of
Thrones style like he'll you up there
doe second he leaves out of town
somebody yeah in the back what I had you
fast yeah do you feel like somebody
that'll get murdered or die natural
causes honestly um I don't know that
I'll get gee whiz I hope I don't get
murdered I don't think I've given
anybody reason to murder me although
that [ __ ] can happen pretty randomly we
had Chris Hansen on here he said that
one of the most random things you notice
is that just you don't you don't never
know there's no real rhyme or reason to
people getting you know if somebody
molest a kid or if somebody gets
murdered yeah I would love to die of
natural causes hopefully not because of
something I ate and then went to sleep
at night thinking you know this this
this you know [ __ ] calzone is gonna
kill me you think you deserve to get
murdered or deserve to die natural
causes who's to say you know you but I'm
asking you do which one do you think you
deserve would you be shocked like here
right now somebody walked up and punch
me in the face yeah I was like you know
what that's for [ __ ] yeah would
you I can think of a couple things you
can think of a couple things yeah it's
almost crazy could do that to anybody
yeah you know what that's for mother
people have reasons for to do all [ __ ]
the guys like who at least that karma
came back fast you know yeah that's it I
mean I would want to
ask again maybe this is the Canadian in
me but I wouldn't mind sitting down with
the man after he punched me in the face
and asked him why did you do that I got
punched better than I got punch right in
the center of the face once and it was
well you know a few times in my life but
as you get older when you get punched in
the face and was probably in my late 20s
got punched me right in the face what
kind of guy wasn't he was a guy he
wasn't if he was I would say based on my
size versus his size he was taking quite
a risk punching me in the face
now which you have to respect that so I
grabbed him and I thought about it for
awhile and then I made him apologize to
my friends he was being shitty to some
friends he was yeah and then he punched
me in the face people are irrational but
as so long as you can talk to them you
know yeah I held him firmly though I
tried to let him know yeah but the Lord
in him yeah they used to have a thing
going through the you know the southeast
and stuff and I don't use this kind of
terminology but this was called this
back in the day called [ __ ] fistfights
right and it was gay guys it was all gay
guys running it and they would put a
boxing ring in a bar and gay guys would
fight and you bet on them would there be
would they sort of give you a back story
sort of like like 24 where they would be
like here's why this guy's mad at this
guy like Donna like that course show the
donor don't well just a little clip
package the griffon can't believe like
if you watch UFC they give like the
here's the beef or they were working on
like I think yes yeah nobody in the bar
was listening to what these guys that's
what's exciting then you pick me who
you're who you rootin for me yeah if you
don't do that then it's just based on
their outfits that's a good point gives
a [ __ ] Griffin a tall a Randall cereal
they're gonna figure this out tonight
but yeah dude they comment people would
bet on them and then you can get you
know pictures afterwards and stuff
different times different times man
different times would you ever do any
road work any vaudeville type stuff or
do you think the road would kill you oh
man vaudeville type stuff like like what
like I get out there be a you know car
not carnie but high in Carnival high-end
carnival [ __ ]
yeah like stepping on a bunch of rakes
and stuff and like like clown noses [ __ ]
like that little singsong I could see
you do in the middle of it
mmm it's a tough road the road is tough
especially when you're doing that I
would imagine when you're doing what you
do you're like oh I get to do some
stand-up comedy now I love doing it I'm
gonna do it tonight but ya know for me
like I can't even play the accordion so
that would probably be it would be hard
for me to justify being out there on the
road I would probably lose money being
on the road doing yeah you would I think
I would definitely lose money and it
would be depressing and lonely ya know
I'm not gonna do it would you ever open
up for me on the road uh sure
Wow that'd be cool huh hey thank you
very much I did you know I would open up
for you to do cheers well I don't really
do I don't really but when you put
together a stage show dude I could see
you having a stage so a musical you know
I'm saying that would be fun
you know I've it's interesting having
friends now we're friends cuz we've
spent this much time together right
again to R if you're just tuning in Theo
and I are establishing our friendship
live podcast form this is this is new
media as it [ __ ] yes truly like if
you and I if we like do more stuff
become buds and [ __ ] then people be like
oh you can [ __ ] watch them you can
literally watch them become friends in
2018 like here's the day and you can
watch it now I do you know having
buddies like you know Chris and Brian
Bobby Lee who I've been friends with for
a long time I do a stand-up is is such a
it's a much different thing than then
then what I do and what what so many
people in the business do it's such a
specific thing but I will say you know
it's like I kind of feel like you know
I've said this to Chris and Brian I feel
like it's an art form really truly
because I'm a fan of you know the
stand-up that I like to watch or
whatever over the years and you know
worn porn stand up
hey you're like you know I had all the
albums and [ __ ] go yeah it had like
Buddha George
and [ __ ] prior and and the guy the
rapist and and yeah and you know like
Gilda live like Gilda Radner oh I gotta
listen to that yeah Robert Klein oh yeah
yeah
you ever hear Mary Clower Jerry Clower
know oh you gotta listen to Jerry klauer
is there my favorite okay and but I feel
like it's an art form under siege
especially now because it's experiencing
a big resurgence over the past you know
handful of years
what does seeds mean well I feel like
here's here's how I feel if you're an
actor you still somebody needs to let
you do it you know what I mean you have
to get through an audition I mean you
can go and make YouTube [ __ ] and do
whatever but if you want to be an actor
you have to earn your spot here and
there actors have to audition all the
time or have some sort of momentum or
name or whatever so if you want to start
out in acting you somebody has to let
you do it if you want to be a musician
you have to have some musical talent or
you'll be found out and chewed up right
away and I'm literally thinking about in
the most rudimentary way like when I was
a kid you know you know a lot of kids
wouldn't play hockey in my town because
their parents didn't want to pay for the
[ __ ] equipment Wow you know what I'm
saying so like like so like you know a
tradition it's like you need equipment
right you need equipment in comedy you
you just need this microphone which I'm
pretty sure it's provided you guys don't
have to bring yeah they have the mic
they're usually yeah so if you go to an
open mic and it's like so I kind of feel
like a lot of the and I'm saying this
I'm not saying this as somebody who
knows what the [ __ ] I'm saying this
purely is an audience yeah to stand up
when I see like total [ __ ] and then
the and this is again my opinion
strictly is an audience member and I
will draw that line I like to enjoy and
just you know not be a comedy head about
it but if I go watch stand-up somewhere
and someone's [ __ ] just [ __ ] then
the next person is great and then it's
like [ __ ] [ __ ] great great great
[ __ ]
it's like the [ __ ] can we get them out
of here and just have this and I feel
like there's just the way that stand-up
comedy is set up there's there's just
too much there's so much [ __ ] yeah
I'm getting super passionate
but it's true it's you you know I mean I
know a lot of bad stuff man I mean you
know and I'm not asking you to get into
that because I feel like no it's fine I
lied about it I can maybe I can say it
because it's not my bread and butter
right what I do at all so far be it for
me to like go you know look I've been
doing what I do for a really long time
so anytime I've done some stage [ __ ]
like some some standup he's stuff it has
to be just like a bit and you know so
like you know I used to do a character
that we used to do on on the podcast I
had with Brian and Chris uh what kind of
guy was it he was a stand like he was a
stand it was basically a stand-up guy
like a sick guy look at what like a guy
that was sick or something yeah he'd
take too many dick pills and his hands
were straight
look how about they were just freak
people out no that wasn't West Palm
Beach that happen to me
what yeah I think you talked about this
earlier on in our friendship about oh
yeah and five minutes ago yeah mime so
um so no I stood this guy and we did it
on the 10 minute podcast because it was
like oh here's a funny thing for like
something to be the bit was like oh he's
a he's a he's a former open mic ER who
is is hey I'm just gonna sit in you guys
do your thing and I'll sit in and they
go and cuz we would do bits so buddy
what from shinik did from Schenectady
right and this good fellow and we just
name is David Greco and he was just like
this guy hey what up and so they would
do their thing and they'd be talking and
he would go ahead what's going on with a
Britney Spears she shaved her head it's
crazy yeah like dude that happen ten
years of it like shut the [ __ ] up unless
you have something good okay that's the
bit so haha and then I was like oh maybe
I'll do it live so I did it a few bunch
of times and it was kind of fun but it
was always a bit and I kind of feel like
someone like me has to come into it
sideways doing like a bit or else or
else she's like I don't like it when I
see man well that could be worked out
man you could figure that out you know
you could have somebody doing you know
playing a straight man on stage and then
you fit you know like I would just love
to see you on the road you know taking
it to the street so that's interesting
you know I really would in some form I
think there's got to be a way because
people just love you seem like everybody
and it seemed like it would be nice if
people could see that well then that's
that's cool and that's interesting to
hear you say that because I I you know
the the the times that I've performed
live have been you know they're not
stand-up eat things you know but I you
know I've done a lot of like madtv's
live audience and live audience sitcoms
that I've done in [ __ ] and and this and
that you know you end up doing stuff
that essentially being in front of a
crowd going hey Mimi and and it's like
well I got a you know I got a I got to
read everybody and do this and you know
it's essentially doing stand up with a
net kind of thing I've been involved in
that sort of [ __ ] and then I've had
friends that are like you know weirdos
in comedy that do do some some weird
stuff who come from more sketch
inscripted but but also before that came
from a stage came from improv game from
yeah putting together a sketch true
can't come from writing and they go well
if you don't want to do that you could
do like I have one friend of mine he's
like oh well when I do a live show like
I come out and I have like a guy who
plays a stand-up bass and it's weird and
I I got a song yeah put a package
together
yeah dude armor when I had 15 minutes of
comedy I would go to colleges and
what would I do oh and I would show up
the day before I would shoot like a
cribs with like the principal of the
school or like a fraternity that's funny
and I would go to their place and like
shoot at all and then edit it together
that night so that was like and I would
do interviews around campus like yeah
you know I heard you they're allowing
guns on campus what do you guys think
you know yeah and people one kid ran off
when I asked him like [ __ ] him Breslau
now so you even run in brought some
buddies gonna gun you down but but I
would ask him all kinds of stuff funny
stuff then I would make out like hey you
know 30 minute video then I would do the
video and then come out and do whatever
little comedy I had and that was the
show I mean I think just these days
there's so much you can mix up I just
think that people would love to see you
out there cheers you know you got to get
out and about
so what let me ask you this why why do
you guys man because you get a natural
claim no I'm really I'm curious yeah get
out of there people will tell you the if
people are listening they'll even tell
you to get out there man you know I
think you'll like Gerard Butler a little
bit people tell you that did I look like
Gerard Butler yeah people do tell me
that several times a day early or not
yeah that's weird and he's always in the
top 100 of the man-on-man magazine
uh-huh see you it looks like you have
another tier Dame I do need to aim for
another tier you're not wrong you know I
I shouldn't even be saying this on on
wax as they say but yeah I was thinking
about doing not the old stand-up
character that I was doing but I've been
thinking about doing a new stand of
character yeah like what else olive eats
let me see what it's like well see I'll
try it
okay I'll pitch it because you know why
I did it at me you know what I'm gonna
pitch it why because hey I'll probably
never do it and be because I feel like
it's it's not a bad thing now to pull
the curtain back a little bit because
we're in the Internet age pull that
[ __ ] back do nothing is special the
whole family's in the bathtub when you
pull that curtain back you see the whole
family's yeah yeah that's right you know
did you hope for when you pull that
curtain back you hope to see all of them
in a line just like like the stickers on
the back of a minivan it's like all
lined up and a dog and a cat coat - just
doing joke just a family doing coke
behind that bathroom curtain that's what
comedy is really dude think about it
order me a bag of yams brother you need
some sweet potatoes and
[ __ ] in the slingshot it's Christmas
some kind of [ __ ] self-made well I
gotta talk about Christmas juice to do
the character well chase nobody Jesus
Christ dude
alright I feel like we invited here to
do character you just been talking about
jungle or some Runkle I've got my foot
why is it as Christ forearms are
sweating somebody's gonna bake you over
the holidays yeah your [ __ ] homes are
wet my arm stroke I don't know took some
dick pills of the am/pm law I figured I
was gonna get in here might as well get
some uppers in me I [ __ ] I slept here
last night I was in the [ __ ] I'll had
some nigiri and then this morning I had
a [ __ ] turkey sandwich cleaned myself
up
took a couple of [ __ ] rhinos yeah
you're ready for the outback anyway
here's my character [ __ ] me
anyway this is literally what I was
thinking yeah what if I did stand-up
uh-huh see this is gonna be the dumbest
[ __ ] thing ever
well but still just get it out I [ __ ]
pitch this to a couple of buddies of
mine the other night I was like hey man
you know what might be funny cuz they
know like the old stand-up carrots no I
got a drum roller so it doesn't work I
gotta make sure it doesn't work I gotta
[ __ ] just [ __ ] stomp it into the
ground first and I pitched it to them
and they went I don't know so that's why
I just want to preface it by saying
other people who I respect in comedy
one's a writer one's a director not
stand up never heard of them do it and
they went I don't know [ __ ] character
here's the character a Chatty Bad Santa
sweaty arms whatever what if you never
do the character it just keeps being
there what if I just go on stage and
pitch the character and never do it yeah
this [ __ ] podcast just goes in
perpetuity through so character dude
well there's really no are you there's
me guys Milwaukee is yeah should he
fight that guy yeah hey beauty
hey here's my ears here's here's my
Brendan Schaub personation ready it's
just a couple words okay hey Dana White
that's it it's a three word
impersonation motto no I don't know beat
listen Dana White that's my home oh yeah
how many countries are there looking up
chin hey chin how do I spell my name
look it up Kofi we'll see you in our
Toledo so here's my character Santa Anna
gonna release some special tickets where
are you gonna be a dry bro or how about
instead of hey Dana wait this is my new
listen Dana White so that's my Brian so
took out one of my written on get him in
a [ __ ] mucho
hey Dana White so there that's 250
episodes of TFA TK in two minutes
you want to see that there you go let's
do it 200 - 200 all 250 two episodes of
TFA TK in two minutes we just do it just
had it head up then we'll package that
up so and then they get that little
redheaded guy in there that guy who has
who knows what probably had disease
you're talking about cheeto santevia
cheeto Santino some guy named a for a
[ __ ] chip you know I didn't watch so
god never something that gets dropped
off in a van every afternoon and thrown
it into a machine where people put
change in and get you out of a [ __ ]
chip bro get your life together dude
it's your life with your [ __ ] cousin
fun yeah boy [ __ ] beautiful off the
thing yeah the thing you crazy [ __ ] you
[ __ ] Joey Diaz that's Joey yes
when Michael Rapaport Instagram oh yes
all good you loser
Donald stroke thing you're gonna drop
that dog and get hit by a car and then
that happens yeah I want to talk to
someone I'm a white privilege white God
Jewish askin Ozzie rare silverback
Hebrew and I [ __ ] porzingis Oh Carmelo
Anthony you [ __ ] Donald Trump da da
look at this [ __ ] guy's gonna jump
through this table and hurt himself you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh he [ __ ] fell I [ __ ] told you uh
here's my characters okay no I don't
want the character do another one and
I'll guess who it is dude I'll do one
and you get alright I'll do this one ah
let me think of one
these people we only know how for the
same people that's just practicing
that's okay we do why coz I'm okay I
mean I'm quite happy to go you [ __ ]
get out of the street now you're gonna
get splashed with water when the [ __ ]
bus drives by you dumb [ __ ] you got
splashed with water you [ __ ] big
thing Donald listen come on the [ __ ]
Paris climate Accord you [ __ ] idiot
you listen a guy McCrone you [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] you [ __ ] you know why -
why does it mean dick stink Donald you
and they look just like each other
that's a perfectly the same you're my
[ __ ] dad and I'm [ __ ] angry their
kids went to the same school yeah you
had your [ __ ] hair straighten cuz you
don't want to look like me you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you yeah
Ravin force it sounds like somebody
stuffed that movie casino who into a
ginger it's like what's going on here
and also while we really do Spike Lee
[ __ ] sucks dick I'll say that that
dudes had one good movie and a bunch of
bad outfits if he weren't at the front
of the Knicks games nobody would give a
[ __ ] about that dude yeah you [ __ ]
put my [ __ ] money to sleep I'll put
your [ __ ] brain to sleep and just
when you're [ __ ] waking up in a
[ __ ] Hospital I'll be there to do it
again because I'm stupid you [ __ ]
you why are you talking like that he's a
straight guy because I'll tell you what
it's casino it's a casino you went over
my [ __ ] ankle
hard luck to you we
reshoot casino yeah with Michael
Rapaport and I don't know like Brian
could play ace could play like ace
Rothschild the [ __ ] and Brendan
Brendan or Chris could play the Sharon
Stone part it's just rich people yelling
at each other man yeah it's all in yet
that movie is [ __ ] that's some big
rich people yelling at each other though
one of the finest rich people yelling at
each other movies yeah oh yeah all right
do one more dude I'll do one day let me
do your character all right okay do my
thing and I was in a train wreck [ __ ]
I'm trying not to laugh is it so hot in
here that one that's pretty good one
it's Patrick I'm gonna pitch this to you
because I [ __ ] god dude I want to go
home it's this [ __ ] thing actually
gonna do Christmas [ __ ] man this whole
thing was Christmassy you got that on I
got a [ __ ] hat it's raising my
temperature what I'm sticking with it
I'm [ __ ] sweating through fur I'm
[ __ ] sweating through fur all over
you yeah where were you when I was
playing in the NBA six on six celebrity
basketball you piece of [ __ ] yeah you
couldn't beat Omarosa in a one-on-one
Dick's thing Donald eckstein Donald
you're right here causing all this
traffic I'm [ __ ] rich and I'm yelling
at you
nobody showed up to your [ __ ]
inauguration you [ __ ] you okay so
here's the care who cares well how does
Michael care so much about it oh well
you got to be passionate he's passionate
about his passion it's a good point but
it's like why take it out like take it
out on somebody else take it out on the
coach of the [ __ ] Knicks that guy's
been a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] for 20
years
well that team is garbage wait a minute
you're talking about taking out his
political views that he would have aimed
at Trump on the departures
be a little more I don't know it be
interesting yeah just try something
different dude that's definitely
different
no he's politically ranting people do
this thing internet and they [ __ ] I
will say that there's that I love that
we live in an age that the Internet is
still the Wild West that you can
literally get on the internet and say
and call the [ __ ] president whatever
the [ __ ] you want and you can do
anything about it people threatened to
kill him didn't Madonna say that I'd
like that yeah let me move it where are
you at Madonna yeah kill him if you want
kill somebody kill somebody kill the
Konex your senior citizen that's [ __ ]
trying to you know [ __ ] you know yes
speaking of the Knicks is she [ __ ]
half of them do dynamic what if Chris
started dating Madonna that would be a
Power Move I wish you would I wish you
would
here's a thing he's got a chance to
really hook up with some old senior
citizen hotties before they you know go
to heaven or don't go to heaven and
there's a few out there oh yeah Jessica
Lange so yeah dude Artie Lange Artie
Lange you know and yeah I did I think
let's see the character okay so here's
the character okay it's essentially it's
me it's me doing stand-up okay some
jokes you know write some jokes try to
get up there for a few minutes
oh yeah definitely didn't maybe I might
even pilfer some of the jokes from the
other character yeah maybe it's a
specific bit probably not here's what it
is though it's me with maybe a slightly
different name and a very very short
well-made wig I could see it and it's
not one of those things where it's like
oh why why can't why wouldn't you just
we'll just take this stupid wig off and
do the jokes well no this character has
his own specific point of view on things
about I don't know mostly what it is
though is me doing stand-up yep slightly
different name mm-hmm and a little short
short brown wig I could see that
I could see you in the smallest wig ever
like a tiny wig just on the back of my
head and I would have a name like Pete
or maybe Philip Stanley Stanley Daniel -
something different
yeah bunion bunions a good name on your
cute name Palma Paul I feel like you
would have any name that would be cute
for a rabbit would be cute for you and
if I and if I uh muffin cotton thumper
Jenkins ladies and gentlemen one hand I
keep smacking against the other means
wonderful a sound for thumper Jacob hey
guys what's up I'm thumper jakey and
here's thumper Jenkins and he's got
three tasty yams he's about to fire
across what if I just and I just I have
like a super colorful name but I don't
but I just uh yeah speak very Canadian
like spunk Wilson yeah spunk yes Bob
Wilson spunk taste test Wilson branch
and sniff Wilson nailed him so I think
this would be something that could be
interesting so technically it wouldn't
be me I wouldn't be doing our union and
doing it for us or not oh that's it no
that's I haven't worked out the rest of
it that's crazy brother you told us all
that yeah Phillip yeah train this is the
worst ending this like boys on the side
or whatever can we go to some of these
videos when bro are you really having a
stroke look at that bro his arms are
soaking wet let's get through this thing
here's a young guy so [ __ ] hot in
here we said that bummed out the door
open that lawyer is not happy down the
hall he just like opened up his door and
looked oh wow there's a wild oh look
here we go yeah
Will Sasso you little [ __ ] balloon
dot how are you buddy um Sam was when he
I hope you doing well from Australia
they you know so well I wanted to know
when was the time you faked excitement
for a Christmas gift
could be from anyone family member
appreciate it boys merry Christmas to
you I like I like his bullet Club
t-shirt I'm gonna say that first what is
that bullet club's a wrestling thing
currently the bullet club would be Cody
Rhodes in the young bucks mostly the
club have been shot no nobody's been
shot well it's in Japan they have a
different relationship with with guns
than we do here yeah you know the bullet
club you know we got you know a couple
of those guys moved out here now they're
just the club but when it was back there
it was you know Prince Devitt AJ Styles
guys like that a Christmas gift that I
was underwhelmed by faked excitement for
faked excitement for yeah I could think
of one a hat Oh nobody likes getting a
[ __ ] hat dude if you get somebody a
hat for Christmas [ __ ] them well
actually my agents used to send me wine
they still do on Christmas and I wasn't
drinking for a while so I'd have to
feign excitement but not last Christmas
because for about a year now you would
remember this from earlier in our
friendship I start I introduce my little
red wine now white wine yes that's
that's [ __ ] that's sugary poison oh
yeah why there's the answer to your
question would have loved if you had
more of a question about the bullet club
but do you what disease do you think
would go best with you if you had have a
unique disease well diabetes right but
I'm talking about something fancy some
high-end you know Bell's palsy I could
see you having a soft side of your face
hoof-and-mouth
oh well palsy I had a friend who had
Bell's palsy yeah a friend I would make
him laugh because it was just so funny
to see him go he did like this John
Christian laughs that's some Canadian
context former prime minister yeah he
had a dog like this and they go don't
even care yeah done to make it done it
doesn't make god damn literally that's
it because there's Anchorage any talk
like this for there
and people and it doesn't make that bang
bang dude yeah everybody and France
sound like they just were coming and
they got hit by a [ __ ] bat in the
spine like what are these videos video
well we go this one's audio hey the
questions for Will Sasso my name's
Matthew from Canada and I want to know I
know what your favorite urban urban
comedian Shawn will be doing for
Christmas
is she expanding with you you know you
handed out some aah James you know I'm
down a comedy store you know what her
eggnog so uh thanks appreciate you guys
that's very cool
that's a that's a he's referencing
something we used to do on the
aforementioned 10-minute podcast yeah
another comedian character Shauna was a
woman who was the the queen bee of urban
comedy the first lady of keeping it real
oh god I haven't heard from Shauna in
about about five or six years do you
know if you what happened in the ten
minute podcast honestly somebody didn't
somebody one of you guys wasn't pulling
their weight no no actually that was it
was it was that we were all pulling too
much weight
no really what happened was probably
around can't remember 2014 to that we
started in doing it in 2012 mm-hmm and
then um I mean it was just it got so
hard with our schedules cuz the guys are
traveling all the time Brian and Chris
Brian's on the west side Chris doesn't
want to leave his house and so and we
were recorded in my place and so it
would just it just got harder and harder
and then we'd kind of done it like we
did the [ __ ] out of what that is right
um and then so you know and Brian was
doing fight during the kid and was like
busy all the time
and Chris too obviously just constantly
on the road so that was it yeah that was
kind of it and so I was like I was like
well why don't we just you know not it
was you know it was kind of like I sort
of you know it just got harder and
harder to do so and we always said to
each other that
you know we're friends and we're doing
this fun thing and as soon as it if it's
not working it doesn't matter
like we're buddies right and so the
[ __ ] podcast with all due respect to
the listeners yeah whom I love
we we couldn't do it so then I was doing
it for myself for a while and then two
other buddies of mine joined in and it
became a very different thing yeah with
my good pals Tommy and Chad Tommy
blodger and Chad Kultgen who are both
very funny resident sounds good though
do you theory yeah and then we tried to
diamond2 the audience down and make the
jokes all reference themselves and kill
our audience we lost thousands of
listeners of course because Brian and
Chris left and then we tried to weed it
down to where if you weren't listening
to all the episodes you'd be completely
lost and then recently we gave it to a
listener the podcast yeah oh well it's
pretty cool it's quite a giveaway iTunes
channel all the social media well I was
pretty cool gave it away and then he had
to stop doing it cuz he's a very busy
man that's pretty cool man
and is there any chance who was that and
where's that now with the feed who's got
control of it nobody
uh yeah Mark Evans was guy he's an
editor had about like a news editor a
real dude and all does all sorts of [ __ ]
works at NBC and do it anymore
and do you is there any chance of a
10-minute podcast coming back no I don't
think so I mean no no I there been any
talk of it no no I mean but it's only
been since the summer it's done I think
what is this next video from Christmas
and wrestling in one okay that in the
chief engineer of laughter and Cheer :
baby I'm from Silsbee Texas I was
wondering I know sass I was a big fan of
a wrestling I was wondering what your
thoughts were on when Stone Cold Steve
Austin kicked Santa in the nuts and then
dropped him into WWE not sure if you
remember that moment is pretty awesome
maybe I'll put a link I'm honest in this
video and I sorta know what y'all
thoughts are on it love both of you and
do I voted for you for guest of the week
on fodder and the kid even though I'm
repping the effing daliyah's Murch freak
hunch man you can vote wherever you want
see you turn that [ __ ] duties wearing
daliyah merch any [ __ ] voter for you
it was nice of them that's very sweet
well I think yeah I'm not gonna have
them really put out there for people to
go vote like I think it's you know it's
the fans of that show so I'm not
publicizing like I'm not telling like
people go voter it's now it's the
listeners if they it's their thing you
know it's it's their thing it's been an
honor to have the strap for a year it's
a sweet strap and and it's it's a cool
thing for your write their show and it's
a wonderful thing to get their listeners
involved and anytime I get to do the
show I enjoy their listenership it's a
good group of people and they're very
engaged now with all due respect to
Brendan and with all due disrespect to
Bryan Callen definitely I don't give a
[ __ ] who wins person of the [ __ ] year
or whatever on their goddamn podcast now
again with all due respect to Brendan
but what do you think of that Bryan I'm
gonna ask him personally I don't give a
[ __ ] yeah well if you know give a [ __ ]
if you don't have a chance to win you
use you don't care that's what I've
noticed hey wait a minute
but I'm just saying and all due respect
no I think you I think you could win and
I think I think it'll be out of you or
delete on no no this other kid is
[ __ ] red lightning whatever that
kid's name is [ __ ] cinnamon Randy or
whatever he went out of nowhere I've
acted like he's got a shot that's
bizarre yeah I think yeah I think blood
Benny might have its name yeah I can row
G Biff or whatever that dude's name is
Jimmy cinnabar [ __ ] Clifford the Big
Red bug and creep dude yeah that guy
shows up out of nowhere what a couple of
he says he has no freckles I'm saying
you know smaller piece yeah
and he's acting like you know he's gonna
win it all dude Kenneth strawberry
okay yeah right little [ __ ] Marcus
raspberry over there little Martinez
very out here it is [ __ ] gingivitis
dude [ __ ] his skin is almost given
out bro a lot of your skin gives out
early by 40 you've just bare you know if
you don't tie your arms to by the side
of your body at night you're [ __ ] the
whole body will follow
gende is a fallin apart he needs a
[ __ ] he needs some [ __ ] gas
station dick dick I need some honking
keep his appendages you got a collar and
[ __ ] little ginger together son he's
got a shot yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] Geoffrey
Indian summer dude somebody said who
should be guest of the year it should be
Bryan Callen I thought that was the fun
is that that's [ __ ] hilarious
no you know yeah I think I think Chris
has got and that's not and I'm not Anna
you know I don't say that to disparage
you the current champion or Chris the
future champion I'm just saying [ __ ]
right yeah [ __ ] Brian and his outfit
yeah dude him what kind of call he's
also dressing very very European race
he's yeah he always wears tight sweaters
and shoes that you don't recognize yeah
what is this when he make those oh you
got him at IKEA someone's making them
somewhere when I'm 51 I'm gonna look
like a [ __ ] homeless alcoholic just
based on what I wear now so I better get
step my fashion up because a sweaty arm
[ __ ] hoodie sweatshirt yeah it's not
is not doing it at 51 now in the cold
sweat two very alarming you got to live
in a castle to it your size if you're
not living in a castle you look like a
[ __ ] well yeah you look like a
[ __ ] weirdo walking out of an
apartment dude I can't walk into a two
or three-bedroom apartment and you're
living in there dude you better have a
moat around your It's A Wrap yeah oh
yeah I got some well I got ya I got a
drawbridge but no no yeah you better
tighten up and get a big you know stick
or something or a hat [ __ ] so scepter
or some [ __ ] I'd rather be outdoors and
it's either castle or outdoors at your
size you can't be running around in the
front you know I got a will for
Barrington I got a wooden
I got a wood crown carved from one stump
oh definitely it's heavy as [ __ ] yeah
but I live outdoors and you need to get
a bird or something we're strong
the kaha spend time around you yes yeah
that you can send a [ __ ] like takeout
wolves and [ __ ] low yeah
Mongolians do or to pick up a little bit
of pokey across the street yeah I'm
saying that be good to get like a golden
eagle that can get some pokey for me
yeah
Glendale pokey I don't live in Glendale
why is it Bobby Lee changed in 20 years
oh yeah he looks exactly the same
yeah he pretty much does he does well I
think we can uh you know cool well down
were these Santa glasses yeah yeah maybe
this would work for my stand-up
character oh wow I liked it dude what if
you're a guy that looks like Santa but
isn't Santa my [ __ ] buddy my buddy
Tommy Bloch of the aforementioned Tommy
blotches we were talking about he goes
you know be [ __ ] hilarious do a
Christmas special and dress up like
Santa
but then the voice is just Hulk Hogan
and never explained it because I think
people's brains work like that like oh
here's something I'm familiar with from
like the 80s yeah and do like do Hulk
but then but I almost look like Santa
and not like being funny with like the
mustache just dress like Santa and then
just do Hulk Hogan's poisons got any
more videos or is that it Merry
Christmas
any more video we should do a Christmas
song I feel like I don't know which one
we should do you guys sing yeah I think
we could sing something um maybe we'll
go back and forth and do some verses
what's a good one that we could really
silver bills do you know do they know
it's Christmas do they know it's
Christmas the pre handicapped people
know it was band aid it was part of the
Live Aid Bob Geldof's Live Aid feed the
world know people don't know that [ __ ]
that's my favorite Christmas song that
was the beginning of final countdown by
can we play it and have it Nick on this
it will be okay well they shut us down
I think this will be fine oh that's
this is the karaoke version yeah see but
you don't know that you don't know the
tune I can hear the tune in these
headphones it was gonna be a [ __ ]
dream right and it's also 12 minutes
long and in a world of Plenty yeah
you're right okay pick something else
let's do this a little bit of improv on
one of these and we'll shut it down cuz
it's the holidays you know this is
Christmas for people this will be on a
Christmas morning
yeah some people yeah I get uh everyone
speaking of the ten minute podcast we
used to do Christmas stuff all the time
you sing songs yeah around Christmas and
people end up they would tell me we
played that on Christmas around the
family some family will be watching this
some silent night yeah silent night boy
this is a silver bells by the London
this is your program you like this one
yeah okay are they gonna have the lizard
no they aren't oh but do one with the
lyrics like karaoke lyrics there we go
there we go oh this looks good huh
traditional I gotta go to therapy
Internet guys it's a key of F and a key
change to G later
you want to start you start city
sidewalks you [ __ ] busy sidewalks
you [ __ ] dressed in holiday style you
[ __ ] you in the air there's a
feeling of Christmas Dickstein
Donald you [ __ ] you children laughing
people passing day after smile and on
every street corner
silver bells you [ __ ] bd8 silver
bells you [ __ ] you dick sting I think
that's the only hell things in the city
look out for the [ __ ] taxicab it's
right in front of you you stupid
[ __ ] you oh I'm a ginger I don't
even know anything you ding-a-ling
Dickstein Donald you didn't go to the
[ __ ] Paris Accord with a [ __ ]
climate change of good you [ __ ]
pulled out of that and you tell the
[ __ ] UN where to stick it
your big stain Donald you tell them
where you gonna be at Bry well I'll be
in a Appleton Wisconsin almost sold out
I'm gonna release some of my special
tickets black rifle coffee
BBE look at my shoes I'm hit is snow
crunch see the kids punch this is
Santa's big scene you [ __ ] you
cooter that's the cool to do wrong that
was great silver Belle what stuff
[Music]
it's Christmas time in the city you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] railing hear
them ring Hitler and it'll be Christmas
Day you're gonna fall off the dam oh you
fat bastard Ivanka's finest [ __ ] bro
look at his [ __ ] teeth he's trying to
jump through the [ __ ] table and kill
a [ __ ] shot got a [ __ ] beer are
you [ __ ] crazy
yeah I'm counting hands laughs am i
Wayne eleven couldn't make a dude that
was lovely that was the that was the we
did the tea fat k guest of the year
Christmas Carol and was that Dolly
Parton who was that beautiful song
I'm sure dolly do you don't want to
learn more about that character
sometimes even felt like ever telling me
about please man I might just hit you up
I'm calling you it like two or three in
the morning and add some layers to it
haha let's go a Theo Theo I was thinking
instead of like a short brown wig what I
like like a sandy brown or maybe some
grey sides cuz I got some gray my what
do you think just get back to me yeah oh
it's [ __ ] so hot and it's not even
hot that's crazy part from the from the
North Pole this is the last podcast will
the stroke says oh it's too hot that's
what they say
he can't even feel one of his arms and
here's a choo choo train coming no
further some warning signs I think yeah
do you smell I'm smelling like all right
I hear sizzling and I smell something
meaty is that a bad sign Merry Christmas
from all of us from Nick Merry Christmas
Gianni that's Jionni's in the background
he's an intern unpaid intern and there's
a we'll look at that on those sex pills
breaking ah Merry Christmas and Happy
Will Sasso ladies and gentlemen
[Music]